everybody was passing on the special I
said I'm putting this thing on YouTube
unless Netflix wants it then I'll sell
it to you and in the show I had multiple
bits just like on Netflix cuz I
got fired from a show on Netflix for a
joke so I was like whatever this is
going on YouTube and then my agent sent
it to Netflix and they turned around
they're like we want to buy it but we
have notes I was like either they put it
on exactly as I did it or I'll just put
it on YouTube and they were like well
you have to at least take the stuff out
about on Netflix and I said I
will take out zero just because I
appreciative of Netflix but I was like
this whole thing is you know for my fans
my career only started to get going I
started doing podcasts and that stuff I
was like the networks never gave me
anything and then they just like all
right fine well we'll put it on as is
then great I literally asked my daughter
she was six at the time I was like what
should I name my special and she had
Nutella like all over her hands and face
she was like specialy wesy I was like
that's it I mean it's very on brand for
you yes